Kings win the draw dowy across to Anderson Cory
out to play it inside the trapezoid Merill around
for dur deflex right on a grundstrom stick and
he scores beats flurry up over the glove side
shoulder and the Kings have the first goal two
and a half minutes in Yeah Carl grundstrom just
picks that puck up along the wall there he had
career 12 goals last year second of the Season
Johnny Merill just moves the puck up here around
the board a puck battle along the board and it
just happens to squirt out and I don't know
if that caught a piece of do Hy stick on the
way in it looked like it may have just changed
directions ever so slightly you do not see NHL
goal tenders especially Mark Andre flurry get
beat from there wild without the defenseman we
mentioned earlier both Spurgeon and gagoski
still out of the lineup for the wild here
tonight and here's your one three through
the neutral zone let's see if the wild can
work their way through the maze get the puck up
on the glass and they score Conor derer ties it
up for Minnesota keeping it simple and then
when you do dump the puck you got to get the
puck up on the glass and the wild catch a nice
break there the puck hitting a St and and then
Conor du are able to cup this Puck and just
kind of Sling it toward the the goal and this
is a very difficult Puck for the goal any goal
tender to to uh to Hartman has it back off the
wall for zuk gell into the middle a drive by B
and they score tipped by capriso and it's 2-1
[Applause] Minnesota well it took the wild the
couple two three minutes to get going in this
game the first three or four minutes was all Los
Angeles Kings wave of four check and offensive
zone time and the Kings having a difficult time
sorting out the play defensively Muk gella with
his League leading six assist put it right on
the on the T there for Jonas broin and that
puck was redirected right in front of the net
there by Carill Capri off and again getting
traffic around the front of the net is always
very very important and okay yeah this this is
good right here but this pass out to the middle
of the offensive zone that to me from that angle
it looked good after video review it's determined
that we have a good goal the play was on top first
year with the golfers there decided to stay back
and try to win a championship and what a smart
move by him and just continue it to to develop
his game they score got loose out front gabov
was the first man who found the loose bucket on
the backand he slides it past Mark Andre flurry
that's the first five on five goal against
strong play by gabov to find this Puck and
it's 22 yeah this is a a set play up there and
K was able to throw the puck right down into the
into traffic and I just mentioned earlier how
the wild have done just a great job of tying
up sticks and bodies unfortunately Sam Johansson
can't hold it's a two-on-one short-handed for the
Kings Doo has more with him Doo fires glove
save flurry the drow there to grab the puck
from Minnesota into Felino back to Hartman final
seconds of the power play Hartman out front Felino
fan on it Rossy holds on his backand swings wide
against Kee out to gdo fires off the post and by
field able to tip it out to Center ice Kings
back at full strength again great traffic in
front of Camp tet there that talk got by him
unfortunately did not get by the crossbar good
traffic there and using that high area of
the ice in the offensive zone Middleton to
fa and now fala with it around behind the net
gabov deflex Faber holds his own duim was tied
up by Roy out front fala able to knock
it out to Center Ice Dubois hustling pass
der he scores Pierre Luke deis with a strong
play able to hold off Conor do and beat Mark
Andre flurry it's 3-2 Los Angeles scored his
first goal the other night against Winnipeg
homecoming of sorts here for pier Luke duah just
a loose Puck beats him to the front of the puck
and just redirects it a little bit look like it
changed directions right in front of Mark Andre
flurry and that one eludes 3-2 Los Angeles
as we go back and forth here in St Paul fala
inter along the wall right on the stick of du he
scores [Applause] again2 Pierre Luke duo with two
goals they come just 8 seconds
apart and the Kings have a 4-2
lead wild down one- nothing
early storm back to make it
2-1 and then three unanswered goals by the
Los Angeles Kings to to take a 4-2 lead here
with 46 seconds left in the first period
a defensive breakdown and Pier Luke dubis
he's able to create a lot by himself but again
he just uh he has time and space and when you
need to make plays at the right right and
wrong time he still uh struggles with that
from time to time Walker chips it off the boards
Johansson moving in Johansson fires and a save by
talot wild find themselves down two goals going
to need to take a few chances offensively maybe
try to pinch maybe pinch down a little
more than you otherwise would early in
a game so going to need to be sharp
here in the third again 28 wins 18
losses Kings coming back with dubis his
shot Hartman got it ahead to zukaro out to the
line talum shot was blocked it's loose out
front and they score Moore grabs the loose
Puck beats Mark Andre flurry and the King
stretch it out to 52 feeling pretty good
about his game as I mentioned this line was
outstanding in Winnipeg Ryan Hartman loses
his stick here along the wall and Trevor
Moore is able to pick up that loose Puck
and get inside and that's the second Puck
we've seen fly over the Blocker on that
side England back to pick it
up for the kings around for
Roy loose Puck Johansson has X and he
[Music] [Applause] scores Pat maroon nice
little Nifty play here is a quick little
two-on-one Marcus Johansson right on the tape of
ericon and he's able to beat cam telvet and some
of those fans that were headed up the stairs
decided to come back down here the wild find
themselves now only down two he's on it in the
corner zuk Carell to Maroon walks off the end
boards ericon and it poke checked Away by talbet
and Kee fires one into the empty net that should
seal it for the Kings they're back up three with
219 remaining Kee this is the play right out here
Works its way out front there and never does
get to Camp T it kind of fanned on it just a
little bit and and kmay who scored 41 goals last
year led the Los Angeles Kings in scoring kind of
C that puck just a little bit and is able to hit
the target at the fights by and Anderson checked
to gain the Zone waits for support got it through
to capriso fir saved by talbat rebound loose and
the Kings clear it'll be a second empty net goal
for Los Angeles and it's 7 to three for the Kings
Lake lazat scores in his hometown great job by
Erikson just fighting for this Puck and drill
cof gets in a great OPP opportunity right there
and then loose Puck pops out there and poo try
to slide it backhander by tbot but the bouncing
Puck eluded him and that'll do it the Kings come
into St Paul and with a couple of empty net goals
late to pad the final margin beat the wild 7 to3